[موسيقى]
كانت حاضره وبقوه ودائما لكن فجاه لم
تعدها لسرحان متواجده بتلك الوفره ايش
اسرارها وليش تغيبت وهل هي اصلا غايبه او
لا كثيره اسئله نحن اليوم في ضيافتها عشان
نتعرف فينها وايش بتعمل عشره سنوات
قبل ما تكوني مثل لانه اول مره بتدربي
صوتي
انا لغايه يعني لغايه سنه 16 او 17 كنت
بشتغل كنت بشتغل
اشتغلت بقى بقيت اعمل رمضان بقيت اعمل 30
يوم رمضان سهرات في الليل بقى قبل السحور
والناس بقى تسهر معايا برنامج منوعات
كبيره عملت خمس نجوم وعملت اني الاوان
وعمل على مدار سنين كذا سنه حوالي خمس ست
سنين انا ركزت في التعلم
انا بحضر كل المؤتمرات والمنتديات
الاعلاميه
والثقافيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي عندي اهتمام شديد
بالثوره الرقميه
مره والله انا بقول انه لا ياتي اي اعلامي
من فراغ يعني انا مازلت زي ما انا بالظبط
كاني على الهوا يعني انا وانا قاعده بقول
الموضوع ده الموضوع كويس قوي ده ممكن
يتعمل بالطريقه الفلانيه اروح مكلمه زميله
في الحياه يعني لا تعني بالنسبه لي الصور
والشهره والحاجات دي انا اهتم بالانسان
اكتر لما تركتي موضوع البرامج التوك شو
هذه اللي على طول بشوف مع كل اسبوع طوال
الوقت
فعليا ما صار في مذيع
فنانين
احساسك انه انا بدي مذيعه فلما صارت مذيعه
اللي هتقابلني
بيقدم فنانين لا هو في الحقيقه عشان ما
نظلمش الفنانين الفنانين بقوا مذيعين
والمذيعين بقوا ممثلين اه يعني الاتنين
بيخشوا المناطق بتاعه
بصي هقول لك حاجه هو لازم يكون للمذيع
وانت مذيع لازم يكون عنده الخلفيه
الصحفيه الثقافيه
زي طرح سؤال ازاي نشوف
الغير عادي في الشيء العادي المهنه عايزه
تركيز يعني
الفنان
الممثل او الفنان يمتهن التمثيل والدرامه
والحياه دي ما بتديهوش التركيز الكامل انه
يكون صحفي هترجعي عشان ارجع انا طبعا انا
بدي برنامج اسبوعي مثلا حوالي فارجع ارجع
ونص يعني ارجع ونص بس ارجع اعمل حاجه لان
انا لو رجعت اعرفي يا سهى انا لازم هعمل
حاجه مختلفه انا لا اكرر نفسي اعمل بقى
برنامج مهم جدا
اسمه كده مهم جدا ان شاء الله شكرا لك
نورتينا اسعدتيني انا مبسوطه اني شفتك انا
كمان يا حبيبتي شكرا جزيلا يا حبيبتي شكرا
لكم